[Music]
it's nine o'clock
and you're watching a sky news special
programme quincy floyd and
neville lawrence the fight for justice
tonight we have
an exclusive interview with george
floyd's son quincy
who says he can't stop watching the
video if his father's final minutes
those eight minutes and 46 seconds under
the knee
of a white police officer in minneapolis
in may this year
george's death led to a reckoning in
race relations in the u.s
and around the world as hundreds of
thousands of people
joined black lives matter protests in a
special report
as part of our coverage of black history
month we brought quincy together with
neville lawrence
whose son stephen was murdered in a
racist attack
in london in april 1993.
stephen's murder marked the start of
significant change in race relations in
the uk
and led to the mcpherson report labeling
the metropolitan police as
institutionally racist tonight we'll be
discussing the ongoing fight for racial
justice both here
and in the us plus we'll be asking how
much has really changed
since george floyd's death in may and
finding out what lessons
still need to be learned and later we'll
be joined by george floyd's high school
friend
cyril white but first sky snow phillips
has this exclusive interview
with george floyd's son quincy
kneeling on the street in minneapolis
where his father george floyd took his
last breath
is a pain that is deeply personal for
his eldest son
quincy his father was killed when a
police officer knelt on his neck
for 8 minutes and 46 seconds i can't
stop watching the video i watch the
video almost over and over
not every day but every now and then i
just think about it
it's a sort of grief neville lawrence
knows all too well
we've brought the two men together for
the first time
when i saw the incident with your dad
being kneeling on down the floor with
that man
kneeling on his neck and the other
officers
around standing and watching tears came
out my eyes
like george floyd stephen lawrence's
racist killing
27 years ago has left an indelible mark
in british society
how did you get through the tragedy of
having what happened to your son
um we had to go into counseling
the old family had to go into counseling
and and talk about it
even now really right now you know if i
went to
if i went to a funeral to see somebody
being buried
i can't go near when they're putting the
per the the
the coffin down i can't go near it
because i'm looking i'm thinking that
i'm re-burying stephen again
in the aftermath of his death america
was left in turmoil
george floyd's name echoed across the
world
i remember watching your dad's funeral
on tv and seeing just how emotional
and just how raw it was for your family
can you describe what it was like for
you
it's like you see them breathing
my knees just kind of buckle i kiss him
in the forehead let him know that
everything's gonna be all right your
son's gonna be here with
your family's here with you you're not
gonna go out and bang
and we were gonna bury him
quincy now drives the cadillac which
george floyd once owned
he's also launched a memorial project in
his hometown
to honor his dad's legacy what is it
like for you when you hear those words
i can't breathe the knee on his neck
said he couldn't breathe
just thinking about what he was saying
it's not going to be very easy
and and for for all the years that i've
been
struggling it hasn't been easy but
you have to have um a ham in view
and the him in view of my family was to
try and get justice
it took us a long time but eventually
got some justice
and you can't give up you know you gotta
keep fighting
in 2012 two men were finally jailed for
life
for the racist murder of neville's son
i have a hard time trusting any cops
right about now
i'm not saying all kinds of bad cops
are not good cops
but shouldn't have to my father said to
me
george floyd's death was a painful
reminder of america's troubled history
of racism and police brutality
three thousand miles apart these two men
are united
in their fight demanding nothing less
than racial justice no phillips sky news
well let's discuss that ongoing fights
for justice now
and at the heart of it is the
relationship between black and ethnic
minority communities
and the police joining me now are diane
abbott
former shadow home secretary and
britain's first black female
mp in a moment we'll be speaking to
france dean jones former president of
the national black police association
and dr christine calendar from
university college london's
institute of education many thanks
indeed for joining us from this evening
diane abbott
if i could firstly start with you you
represent a constituency that is perhaps
one of london's most diverse
constituencies
the death of george floyd in many ways
have shown a light on
race relations here in the united
kingdom how would you describe
that relationship between the police and
the communities they serve
well my constituency is very diverse and
i'm very proud of that
um in terms of relationships between the
community
and the police i have to say that the
figures don't lie
and black people are more likely to be
stopped and searched
more likely to be handcuffed or even
more likely to be
fined under the corona virus regulations
so there is still an issue just as i was
at the
time of stephen lawrence's death about
disproportionate use of police powers
against people of color and why do you
think that is because most people would
say that the vast majority of police
officers are good officers
they get up every single day to do a
good job and serve the communities um
that they cover
so why are you seeing this um
disproportionate impact on
largely young black men up and down the
country
well i mean you have a police officer on
the panel and she's better able to tell
you
that i am i'm not saying the vast
majority of police officers are bad
people
but i'm saying the figures do not lie
and there's no question that it hasn't
helped relationships between
the police and the community dr calendar
again many would say that this is a
problem that's exclusively
not about the police um we need to look
at all our institutions across society
do we need to have a hard look at
ourselves
we do because no matter what metric we
look at
if you look at housing if you look at
employment education
criminal justice system as as diana just
mentioned
health no matter where we look we are
seeing
vast discrepancies between the outcomes
for black people in this country and
everyone else
and how would you explain that why why
is that i mean many would say
britain is not a racist country it's not
a racist society so
why are we seeing these disparities
i think we really need to start
unraveling this conversation because
what all of these various um
areas where we see disproportionality
show
is that socioeconomic status
has a significant impact on health
outcomes on educational outcomes
on likelihood to be involved in criminal
justice system and so on
so whatever analyses we use we have to
always come back to the significance
of socioeconomic status and as a
community
we are located in the lower echelons of
that
of that criteria diane abbott would you
agree with that this is
largely about socioeconomic status
it's partly about class but that doesn't
explain
why black working class
young men are more likely to be stopped
in search than white
working-class men there is no question i
mean most
police officers are good guys and so on
but
some of them do approach people of color
with certain preconceptions you remember
my colleague dawn butler
who has stopped she was in i think quite
a nice car
with a black male and she was stopped
by the police they just assumed that two
black people in a nice car
must be up to no good dr calendar you
spoke about
unraveling this conversation so where do
we start
well i think we already have a lot of
information at our disposal there have
been
various reports that have come out since
covid and even before that
um so we actually know what some of the
issues are
where i think we haven't been very
proactive is actually acting
on the many many recommendations that
have been made by various
reports we seem to want to continue a
rather circular conversation
but actually we now need to actually
make some action and actually look at
what this data is telling us
and do something about it um diane
abbott dr calendar there
um picked up on the point of covid um
do you think this is once again an
example a firm the disparities that
exist in society we've seen
at the figures or the latest figures
regarding this pandemic and how
it is largely affecting those from an
ethnic minority background
yes i mean when we went into lockdown
and covid was on the rise it was
horrifying day
after day you would see photographs on
the front page of the newspapers
of nhs workers that had died
and the majority of those workers were
black minority i think of the first 23
doctors that died
22 a black minority ethnic it reminded
us
of the enormous service that
black and large ethnic people how they
serve in the public sector and in the
nhs
but it also reminded us of how
vulnerable we are
dr collins you've spoken in the past
about us needing
culturally competent organizations i'm
interested to know
what you meant by that and how all of us
can
apply that in the institutions where we
work
well it's quite clear that for a lot of
our public services that when it comes
to
people from black minority ethnic groups
their needs
aren't being served in a way that is
equitable
so there's something there about the
institutions this is not about the
people this is about the institutions
and i think we all need to look very
carefully at
our hidden biases and assumptions that
we may be
you know some of these vices we may be
aware of them some of you may not but we
do need to look organizationally
at whether the offer that we have to
all of our communities is serving each
of them in an equitable way
so i think a great deal of introspection
and asking ourselves some very difficult
questions
and facing some realities is in order
diane abbott people do make assumptions
based on race i mean
we were talking about coronavirus and
people arrested under the coronavirus
legislation
some of these people were black men who
happen to be nhs workers on their way
to work we have to be willing to examine
our preconceptions about other
communities i think
actually younger people who are more
likely to go to school alongside black
people going to uni
you know they're less likely
quite often to have those preconceptions
that there's too many people
in our public services who've never
had to examine their unconscious bias
dr calendar what is your position on
this issue of stop and search it is
a subject that we've been speaking a lot
about them in recent years from your
point of view
is there a place for it does stop and
search work or is there a danger that
you
alienate some sectors of society again
uh predominantly
young black men
well i i'm old enough to remember its
predecessor the sus laws
um and i think stop and search
unfortunately is operating in
a kind of similar way um i take on board
the
issues within our community with crime
and it's important to tackle that
but when we look at the kind of
turnover rate in terms of stop and
search and whether or not it leads to a
prosecution
we can see that in a lot of cases
that the percentages don't work actually
we have
i think in london was it 25 of young
black men
had been stopped and searched we have to
find another way
of using the local intelligence we have
so that those people who are going about
their business day-to-day business
do not feel that they have to constantly
be aware
or alert to the possibility that they
will be stopped
and searched by the police i'm going to
bring in francine jones a former
president of the national black police
association thank you for joining us um
francine on that point of stopping
search
what is your view do you think that
there is a place for it because this
debate has been going on
for a number of years now about whether
it alienates
isolates certain groups in society what
do you make of it
a couple of sound issues there with
france dean francine we will try and um
re-establish the link with you diane
abbott i mean what what are your
thoughts a place for stop and search in
the country
of course there's a place to stop and
search but that is
evidence-based stops i don't think
anybody argues
that the police have specific evidence
they shouldn't be able to stop somebody
and search someone
what is poisoned relationship with the
community is
random stop and search the brixton riots
in the early 80s was
caused by a mass stop and search
operation i think it was called
operation
swamp so if that's the evidence that's
one thing
but if you are just picking out people
at random
whether they're young black men or even
increasingly nowadays young muslims
that is bound to poison relationships
and what we find
with that random stop and search that
the most thing that they find
is small quantities of cannabis for
personal use it's not
random stop and search is not an
effective way of dealing with knife
crime and gun crack
francine jones random stop and search
does that poison the relationship
between the police and communities
most definitely and as diane said you
know there is a use there is a place for
stop and search because what else do we
have
we certainly don't want to go back to
sus and
the problem is that there's racial
profiling going on
with regards to young black men and
you know that needs to be dealt with and
i don't like the trend that i seem to be
seeing now around
handcuffing black men before you've even
told them why you want to talk to them
because at the end of the day
if stop and search is used correctly
then we shouldn't be stopping people who
are not committing crime
and francine on the point of the the use
of restraints i mean i
saw a figure released by the
metropolitan police over the summer that
uh black people are four times more
likely
to be restrained by police than than
their white counterparts
what is your explanation for that
i think that um from my experience of
working in the police service
that certain people from certain groups
get stereotyped
and when a police officer who has a
racial bias
sees a black man the first thing that
comes into his head
is that i'm going to have to handle this
in a certain way and it's usually more
use of force
than they would normally use on anybody
else
so dr calendar how do we unpick that
where what points do we start from
well that's a big question um i think i
think we already know what the issues
are and once we know what the issues are
then we can
work towards solutions we know that
there's a disproportionality
um in relation to stop and search with
um young black men
um so we have to look at what what are
the triggers
um that might make a police officer stop
the young black man
and i think it's a process of education
you know not every young black man you
see out there in a hoodie and wearing
trainers
is up to no good you know there's very
many professional black men who dress
like that
they similarly get stopped and i think
we do need to kind of
support our colleagues to have
a better racial literacy a better
understanding
about race a better understanding of
their um biases
so that they can work on those and think
about how those biases
impact the way in which they interface
with black communities
diane abbott have the police made
progress in recent years since the days
of the release of the mcpherson
um report what progress have you seen on
the ground
what are your constituents telling you
well i think the police are more likely
to talk the talk
about um anti-racism than they were when
i first became an mp
um 30 odd years ago but what my young
constituents tell me in particular
is what upsets them is the way the
police talk to them
um and i think there is still a long way
to go and just to add something
um to what one of the other people on
the planet was saying
of course it's an issue about young men
and hoodies but frankly
who if you're a black person who doesn't
know
some perfectly respectable black man who
happens to drive a nice car
who's found himself stopped by the
police i mean the offense
they're calling america driving it's
black the
from the mere fact you're driving a nice
car they just assume
you must have got the money for it the
wrong way
francine how important is representation
i mean do we need to see
more police officers from particular
communities
serving those communities going back to
those communities as
police officers it is that crucial
because
if you think about the government's
launch for this extra 20 000 police
officers that they have promised
is that a golden opportunity for that to
happen
yes it is a golden opportunity for that
to happen
but it's not we seem to concentrate on
the numbers it's not about the numbers
it's about representation in ranks
where you have influence to make a
change
that's where we're missing we have you
can get as many police officers as you
like
in at the bottom end but if they're not
if they cannot get the opportunity
to be in in a position of influence
then nothing will ever change we've only
to history
had one black chief constable ever
so why is that so
and it seems like the higher up you go
in the police service the harder time
you will have
and you know you'll probably be the only
person
the only one that looks like you at that
level
in not the big forces but certainly
the the smaller forces outside of london
and the big urban
areas it's about representation in the
higher
ranks that's what's needed
dr calendar final thoughts
just to build on on the previous point i
think it is
it is about representation in the higher
ranks but it's also about
representation in all areas not just
areas that serve our community
because white young white children need
to see
people who look who do not look like
them in positions of authority as well
and diane abbott was a serving member of
parliament if there was one lesson that
we could all learn
from the death of george floyd um what
do you think that lesson should be
well it's really important that
the police are trained properly and that
we try
and eradicate the undue
use of force because that's how
situations like george
floyd happen and we still see
that black people are more likely to
have violence jews against them will be
handcuffed
by the police than other people okay
diane abbott's member of parliament
francine jones and
dr christine calendar many thanks indeed
to the three of you for
joining us um this evening thank you
you're watching the sky news special
program quincy floyd
and neville lawrence the fight for
justice after the break
we'll be asking if the protests that
have taken place in cities across the uk
have made a difference to the lives of
black people and
finding out what more needs to be done
welcome back you're watching a special
program quincy floyd and neville
lawrence the fight for justice
part of our coverage of black history
month on sky news
in an exclusive interview today george
floyd's son has told off
of the moment at his father's funeral
when he told him he wouldn't let his
death
be in vain since the killing of george
floyd in may
black lives matter protests have taken
place around the world
with hundreds of thousands of people
taking to the streets to demand justice
sports stars from around the world have
followed colin kaepernick's lead and
publicly taken the knee
and statues like this one of slaver
edward colston in bristol have been torn
down
with many others going to museums
well black history month is of course
about education and when the history
books are written
2020 could well be a pivotal year but
how much has really changed and what
still needs to be done
or joining me to discuss that is
catherine ross founder of a museum on
the first museum in the uk
to celebrate caribbean heritage culture
and social history
dr jason ardein assistant professor of
sociology
at durham university and hackin adi
professor of the history of africa
at the university of chichester and the
uk's first black history professor
thank you all for joining us in this
evening uh catherine ross if i could
firstly start with you do you think
we're witnessing a seminal moment when
it comes to
our understanding of black history here
in the uk
most definitely yes this is going to go
down in history as perhaps the most
significant black history
month celebration and commemoration
definitely from its start we've had to
battle with covid and all the issues
that that's thrown up
things like our housing jobs
things that have held us back or put to
such a
disadvantage started to come to the fore
other people understood we have been
talking about it
in our communities but now everybody was
able to hear about that
then followed just as we were dealing
with that we we had the
george floyd murder and that rocked
everybody um so yeah it's going to be
a difficult year but good in
the sense that black lives matter has
come to the fore
and um perhaps it's not the right use of
words but
leading the charge it's helping people
around the world
to understand what we have been saying
um
just within our own communities or when
we come out and knock on the doors of
authorities
you know they haven't really heard they
haven't
opened the door fully to us and
so yeah we are going to make a
difference
dr our day 2020 has been quite a year
for britain's minority communities
it has um good evening first and
foremost and thank you for having me it
has been
a tumultuous year in many respects but i
guess before the kind of seminal events
of the summer and the murder of george
floyd
um we were moving we were in a direction
where society has been kind of
splintered
and fractured because of issues around
race and racism
and probably more uh personally the
interweaving of it within our
institutions and how it structurally
disadvantages people of color
um in britain and globally speaking so
we are in a seminal moment i do think
there is something about this particular
course or moment in time that feels
different
it's moved beyond i think the enforced
period of reflection
that came as a result of the lockdown
has actually made people reconceptualize
um one what what allyship may represent
and two and more importantly to really
move
racism from the periphery to
and the margins to the center and really
prioritize that as a political
and social issue and professor adi
briefly what can you tell us about black
history and also
why is it so intrinsically linked to
european history and culture
what can i tell you well uh as far as
britain is concerned it's an extremely
lengthy history uh some 2 000 years
perhaps 3 000 years we're talking about
i think the difficulty is that
that history in britain has often been
hidden
or obscured um it's something which is
is not as well known about as it as it
as it should be people
feel excluded from history people feel
that history has been
distorted um i wouldn't say that
this history is only related to european
history
it's more that the history of britain is
related to the history of africa the
history of the caribbean
the history of other parts of the world
but often this
this these connections between britain
other parts of the world is obscured
it's hidden
and therefore those who originate from
other parts of the world
their history and their contribution to
britain's history is also obscured
as we know now probably the some of the
first britons were
uh people of color to use a common
expression
so even our conception of britishness
our conception of englishness
actually needs to be reconsidered we
need to look at
history as it is as it was it's not
simply a history of the white men of
property
it's a history which should include
everybody and the
importance of understanding that history
is not just to understand the past
but to be have some understanding of the
present world
uh have an outlook on the present world
that enables us to
to operate uh today to look at the world
to understand the world and hopefully to
change it for the better
so catherine this is fundamentally about
equipping
our young people with the knowledge of
of
of black history irrespective of the
race of that young person
oh most definitely um whenever we do our
work in schools or when
um young people come to our exhibitions
it's people it's young people of all
different ethnicities
and they always say we do this or we use
that
and then we find ways of connecting and
that's quite important for young people
they need to know they're part of
something that's
you know a whole and something that's
been going for a very long time
so um yeah um history
is now an exciting thing for young
people
and this black lives matter um has um
involved people of all different age
groups and different ethnicities
so we're all learning together we're all
standing together
and i'm very confident that we're going
to get some real
sustainable change uh dr rda the the
argument goes what young people learn in
the classroom
fundamentally shapes the person that
they become to be
from a sociologist's point of view i'm
wondering whether
that knowledge will help to tackle some
of the disparities and the inequalities
that exist in society
or is that too much of a simplistic
argument
i wouldn't say it's a simplistic
argument and i totally
accept the right for people to reject
that way of thinking but
i think importantly you know education
is a microsome society and
one of education's fundamental remits is
to prepare people
to take their place within society i
think one of the more kind of personal
things is this idea of
the teaching of black history is for
black
to the people of everyone it's the
detriment of every single
um british citizen or global citizen to
not have that history
in trying to navigate and transfer a
multicultural and multi-ethnic
society so to me it becomes a
fundamental part of that toolkit you
need to actually
traverse society and engage with people
from different diasporas
and different types of communities
populations ethnicities and et cetera
and dr addy i guess when you speak to
many people
about black history and where it begins
many will say
it starts with the winross generation we
all know that is
far from the truth um does
is britain duty bound to change that
narrative
um or is it is it up to the individual
to educate themselves
about that history
well i would say it was both obviously
schools universities the media
those who have a a possibility of
educating others
we have that responsibility at the same
time
of course individuals can read can
can find out can investigate these
things
themselves but i think that the problem
is that
history is often presented in a
distorted way
it's falsely falsified in various ways
and that
creates difficulties for people
especially for young people
but also for older people it distorts
our view of the world it confuses us
about the past
as well as the presence so in some ways
we could say
it's perhaps not surprising that um
the truth about the past uh isn't isn't
told just to sometimes the truth about
the present isn't told uh we can all
remember
recent examples of government trying to
change the
type of history that's taught in schools
trying to exclude
uh whole sections of the population from
from
historical study and this historical
inquiry
so i think that it's it's not just uh
there are reasons why history is not
presented in
its its entirety and it's it's sometimes
said that those who are
those who are in power as it were that
they attempt to shape the kind of
history which is which is told and which
is related to others they try and
um they try and condition the way that
we
we see the world so we all have a
responsibility to try and enlighten
ourselves try and
understand the world as it is as it was
but of course
we call on those educators schools
universities the media and so on
to do much more and not do just much
more in october because
having something called black history
month in october
shows us that there's a problem that
there's a problem for the other
11 months of the year that this history
is is more or less hidden again so
what's important is that
history is presented in a way that
everybody can understand it
for 12 months of the year everybody's
included throughout the entire year
and as i say we all have a
responsibility to contribute to just
telling the truth about the world
dr arder i've heard some observers argue
that we shouldn't be celebrating black
history month because
black history is british history british
history is black history and what you're
doing potentially
is separating the two which could lead
us all down a difficult and dangerous
path
what would you say to those observers
say to those observers that i think
there needs to be
an engagement specifically in black
history
particularly because there's always been
kind of a nostalgia for
emitting black history for um
neutralizing black history and the
contribution of black people to
british society and i think one of the
things that becomes really important
is you know the fact you know we have
some george's day we have loads of
different memorandums that kind of
acknowledge
and celebrate you know parts of our
history
and do it in really kind of secular ways
in terms of
you know on one particular day it would
be this and one particular day will be
that and i think
you do need to have an acknowledgement
of
that contribution by black british
people and i think it's
not i don't think i think it's a
reductionist to kind of take the
approach that you know you're separating
those two things
i think they're in many ways symbiotic
and it should be interwoven within
british history generally speaking and
as kind of
professor adia said it's really really
important that actually
it becomes the norm rather than being
kind of reduced to
one month and actually that is the
actual issue
that it's celebrated for effectively 30
to 31 days
in a year when actually it should be a
365-day
kind of venture in terms of it should be
interwoven within
um our societal and
kind of ignitarian vernacular in terms
of how we speak how we talk
how we engage in these different
discourses and catherine ross
when it comes to teaching black history
in schools does it matter about
who teaches it because if it does i
guess it raises many questions about a
representation
or should it not matter fundamentally
it's about the fact that black history
is taught in schools full stop
yeah because if it's part of the
curriculum then the teachers have to
deliver it
so it wouldn't really matter um
what ethnicity that the teacher is but
obviously
if it's somebody um who's who's of
ethnic origin
um as we would say we can tell it's
sweeter
as a caribbean expression you can put
more in it
because it's something you're very
familiar with and is part of your
experience
but um can i just go back to say that i
think teaching
young people starts in the home we have
to go back to that family responsibility
it's been great over the period of covid
when people are in lockdown
and we're able to communicate and share
a lot of important heritage information
with their children
so i think we need to go back to that
but we do pay our taxes
so we do expect to hear more about
black heritage through the schools
and in the museums and other established
heritage places
and there are as much hours so they
should be telling our story
and they should present it in a way that
will
be attractive and interesting um because
we're
they're perhaps telling the story to a
group of people that haven't really been
part of that culture for a while
so we've they have got to start thinking
creatively
and innovatively about that i know
a lot of museums are are working we've
have
helped a lot of them with writing new
labels to explain
things that they've got on a show that
they didn't fully understand
so again the community can assist
heritage organizations with that and we
can support them in that
and dr addie um i don't know about you
but
quite a lot in the past i've heard
the phrase that this is a moment of
racial reckoning
um what do you understand that to mean
that i understand it to mean anything um
certainly this year
there has been an upsurge in people's
opposition to racism
and eurocentrism in all its forms
um and that's very much to be welcomed i
mean it's it's perhaps an unprecedented
upsurge
people showing that they're you know
they're fed up
you could say with the way that the
powers that be
operate in this society as well as in
societies throughout the world but
that doesn't necessarily change anything
i think it's up to us to continue those
struggles that have been going on
for many years for many centuries um
for example we've seen the government's
uh comments recently on this whole
question of the glorification of
those who committed crimes against
humanity the the government is uh
intent on glorifying those who committed
crimes
whereas the vast majority of people in
this country it seems want to
to remove that glorification want to end
that glorification
so that is a way in which history is is
being is presented in different ways if
you like and
i think even the government accepts that
uh there are different views different
approaches to history
and so the question is what do we what
kind of society do we want what kind of
history do we want
and and who should decide how can we
actually become decision makers about
what we learn
and what goes on in society whether
there is racism
whether there is discrimination whether
there is a
a wind rush scandal and so on these are
things which are
um perpetrated as it were by the powers
that be
and what this year is shown is that
majority of people
don't want this kind of society they
want change but then it's up to
the majority of us who want that change
to do something about it
dr arder just very briefly if there was
one aspect of
black british history that you'd want to
focus on
specialize on what would it be
great question um i guess the
contribution of
black british people to building a
country you know there's not one
thing in particular but i guess you know
the windrush generation
and their contribution to british
society over a sustained period of 70
years i think
that needs to be celebrated more and i
think it's really really important that
we acknowledge
the roots that those individuals have
planted for
you know many britain's of color still
to reside
in you know i guess a fair
and equal society that's the wish
um and there's still a lot of work to be
done with regards to that and i think
that for me
is really the hallmark of that um you
know when i think of
black british history i think of that as
a really seminal
kind of moment in that history and a
generation of people
that have really built this country in a
way that you know
has never really been respected or not
dr jay sanadi professor hakim adi and
catherine ross fascinating discussion
many thanks indeed for your time thank
you
and quincy floyd and neville lawrence's
conversation forms the basis of the
latest episode of the black history
month sky news
daily podcast which will run throughout
october you can listen on the sky news
website
apple and google podcast and on spotify
and for more stories on black history
month visit the dedicated section of the
sky news website
and app at www.skynews.com
forward slash black history month